die der bundestag heute wichtige
entscheidungen sind wir weiter in einer
epidemischen lage und der bundestag hat
gesagt ja noch drei monate sind wir
klaus trotz 253 gegenstimmen und da sind
übrigens fast beim selben thema wie wir
gerade waren mich stört das extrem die
epidemische lage in nationaler tragweite
wurde verlängert das bedeutet auch dass
der staat weiterhin eingreifen kann am
anfang also ausgeschlossen wurde hatte
nico ernst laage und wir haben es jetzt
haben wir den impfstoff und ich finde es
eine absolute frechheit vom staat nun
diese lage weiter zu verlängern obwohl
wir in einer ganz anderen position sind
wir haben impfstoffe können gegen kroner
maßnahmen machen dem start steht es
nicht mehr zu in unser privatleben
einzugreifen und diese lage ist
natürlich die hintertür für den staat
weiterhin lockdown zwängen zu können und
alles weitere und ich möchte endlich
wieder in der welt leben wo ich nicht
mehr bevormundet werden obwohl der star
dahin zurückkehrt wo er herkommt dass er
nicht mehr ein starker staat sind
einfach über mein ganzes leben
entscheiden kann beispiel lockt
das interessante aber heute ist ja das
alles raus gestrichen worden ist fast
was zuletzt als unerlässlich gegolten
hat also das bedeutet entweder die
politik hat in den letzten monaten
sozusagen die unwahrheit gesagt und
übertrieben oder sie machen jetzt etwas
verantwortungslos ist und da sagt auf
meinen journalisten gehören so kurz vor
der wahl wenn man den menschen ihre
freiheit zurück geben also sozusagen mit
der freiheit bezahlen das ist schon oder
mit der freiheit stimmen kaufen das ist
ein neuer neuer zungenschlag aber was
ändert sich denn jetzt genau also was
was ist denn jetzt anders oder besser
oder schlechter oder bleibt gleich das
noch mal aber jetzt mal als fakt was was
ist denn also erst mal wo die jetzt da
es ist immer noch möglich durch diese
epidemische lagen arznei tragweite darf
der staat mehr sachen bestimmen was er
vorher nicht durfte also eigentlich
bleibt jetzt alles wie gehabt auch in
den letzten fünf monaten das sind muss
klaus noch mal kurz ausführen was ich
jetzt so stark verändert hat im zentrum
ist so die inzidenz ist weg und sind
dazugekommen sind sozusagen die
krankenhaus die auslastung und das muss
ich sagen fasziniert mich schon weil
viele kommentatoren von anfang an gesagt
haben lasst uns doch auf die
krankenhausbetten schauen denn da kommt
sozusagen zum schwur darauf kommt es an
dass man betrachtet worden
der das ganze pandemie geschehen nicht
versteht und jetzt ist es auf einmal
doch richtig ist schon ziemlich
erstaunlich finde ich ja also vor allem
weil ich auch diese krankenhaus zahlen
oder krankenhausbetten zahlen kann man
ja auch nicht mehr wirklich genau
vertrauen weil weil da ja auch das nicht
ganz sauber durchgelaufen ist ich bin
ich bin gespannt aktuell ist also eine
gewisse grund lockerheit ich glaube ich
dass ich ja auch in der
veranstaltungsbranche tätig bin sicher
diese unterschiedlichen regeln und
gängeleien jeden tag mit wann kann man
wieder auftreten wo nicht welches
bundesland hat welche regeln was ist
möglich oder nicht wie viel mehr aufwand
was kostet das mehr und jetzt hat man
noch so eine gewisse coolness aber es
wird schon wieder die angst natürlich
hoch gesetzt und wir sind ja jetzt im
vergleich zum letzten jahr schon wieder
bei viel höheren inzidenz zahlen obwohl
so viele geimpft sind und ich bin
gespannt wie sehr diese lockerheit dann
so bei einer inzidenz mal von 34 500
oder so dann hier in deutschland sein
was wäre dann deine vorschlag was
wünscht du dir eine größere lässigkeit
oder ergreift ich dann auch die sage das
was ganz schlimmes passieren kann ja es
ist das leben ist halt risikobehaftet
das ist halt so was wir alle jetzt hier
gelernt haben und es gibt einfach ein
paar regeln das ist ja genauso wie dem
impfen also wir können es ja erzählen
wie wir wollen das impfen die einzige
geschichte ist die wirklich nachweislich
was bringt egal ob es jetzt nun 75 78 67
prozent oder besonders wenn aber es ist
besser als nichts und
und ich kann diese dieses dieses dieses
dieses festhalten doch gerade von
impfgegnern sehr schwer nachvollziehen
es gibt einfach ein paar regeln ich habe
das auch zum beispiel mit dem rauchen
jetzt in letzter zeit verglichen ein
raucher jemand der gerne auch dass er
seine eigene möglichkeit das macht aber
er kann nicht in ein restaurant gehen
und einfach sind die zigarette anzünden
und sagen so ich möchte aber rauchen das
ist mein freiheitsrecht und genau solche
regeln werden früher oder später für
leute kommen die nicht geimpft sind die
können einfach nicht erwarten dass sie
alles genauso machen können nur einfach
ums machen zu wollen funktioniert
einfach nicht gehört einfach
gesellschaftlich mit dazu dann können
sie sich zwar nicht impfen aber sie
müssen einfach mit einschränkungen
rechnen
ich habe auch mit der erheblich durch
die vordertür kein problem ehrlich
gesagt weil dies dem pflicht machen naja
ist meine ich ich ich wenn es das
einzige ist muss man in einer art und
weise sie kommt ja so oder so also ich
meine ich zum beispiel als jemand der
auch auf veranstaltungen und so sagen
und wir wollen irgendwie die normalität
wieder haben dann muss das an irgend
einem gewissen zeitpunkt kommen aber es
ist es verhärten sich die fronten
und ich meine clique auch anfragen
irgendwie so für kannst du bitte hier
mal zum impfen auffordern so ich weiß
nicht ob so ein schwarzweiß bob der dann
mit der bundesregierung läuft und wo
wieder mehr prominente einander sind
jemand sagt ob jetzt dass sie mich aber
impfen oder ich sehe ja auch wie zum
beispiel bei meinem heimatverein
hannover 96 gab es zum beispiel so eine
impfaktion jetzt am freitag im stadion
da waren fast 10.000 leute haben sich 56
leute impfen lassen also da ist es ist
schwer würde macht macht ihr das dann
bei deinen veranstaltungen geimpfte
kommen rein getestete nicht wenn es nach
ihr ginge für mich ist es ehrlich gesagt
ich kann es ich kann es ja nicht
bestimmt wenn es nach mir gehen würde
ist erstmal das was grundsätzlich an am
einfachsten ist weil dieser ganze papier
aufwand den man hat diesen ganzen auf an
diesen mehraufwand mit dem sitzen und
dann da und im schachbrettmuster und ich
habe ja auch bin ja auch von betroffenen
gab eine veranstaltung open air in köln
dann ist es sehr schwer ich auch den
leuten oder auch für jemanden
nachzuvollziehen wenn der fc köln vor
16.000 spielen kann aber man im
tanzbrunnen köln wo teilweise bis zu
10.000 leute sind man nicht vor tausend
leuten spielen kann weil an dem tag
gerade wieder die inzidenz von 35 ist
dann aber eine woche später wieder
gekippt wird dann ist aber schon meine
veranstaltung abgesagt und so zieht sich
endlich die veranstaltung eigentlich
habe ich bin ja mittlerweile
draufgegangen auch dieses jahr ich habe
den leuten gesagt entweder ganz
stattfinden oder die seit ab weil ich
kann ja teilweise keine tickets sich
2009 10 verkaufte man zumindest in kinos
und war letztes jahr auch da merke ich
es noch einrichten also es ist eine
andere stimmung aber mittlerweile ein
letztes jahr aber so wir hatten drei
monate lockdown alle firmen sowie ganz
lustig
[Applaus]
konzert karten geschenkt bekommen ein
konzert das hätte jetzt stattfinden
sollen im september in berlin ist jetzt
abgesagt worden verschoben worden auf
mai
2023 ja aber also stehen dieses jahr in
drei jahren wird es nach und wer weiß ob
nach wird aber das muss man sich mal
überlegen also frisch gekaufte karten
also vor zwei drei monaten gekauft für
september jetzt mai 2003 die leute sind
auch sehr kritisch das merke ich auch
all sowie tickets gekauft werden ist
sehr
auch die leute sind auch nicht so dass
sie jetzt sofort in so einem stadion
wollen oder irgendwo also es geht keiner
hin gegangen zum konnte hat es noch klar
ja aber aber in so eine grundangst also
wenn man das organisieren ist durchaus
da wenn das wetter stimmt das die leute
selber ein bisschen zurückhaltend das
sind dann hat der bundestag heute alles
richtig gemacht denn er nimmt ja dieses
sorge auf und sagt wir sind noch nicht
wieder im also wenn sind sozusagen wenn
ein parlament eine mehrheit stimmung
aufnimmt verhält es sich jetzt nicht
schlecht weg frei
die leute müssen sehr ich finde die
leute müssen selber entscheiden also
jeder begibt sich ein gewisses risiko
das haben wir ja auch gesehen also ich
mache ihr habt ja auch gefordert alle
stadien voll dann kommen die zahlen aus
england sieht man gut haben gab schon
3000 infektionen es ist schon ein risiko
da das muss jeder für sich selbst
einschätzen oder abschätzen inwieweit
möchte er ihn zu einer veranstaltung
gehen wo es halt passieren kann ich muss
einmal noch auf dich einfach ein klasse
ich verstehe einfach nicht aber
vielleicht jan ist ja mein chef und
unsere politik chef aber ich verstehe
ganz persönlich nicht wie konnte es sein
dass der bundestag heute die
dreimonatige verlängerung der
epidemischen lage beschlossen hat
aufgrund von warum also die lage ist
doch gerade nicht so die impfquote ist
nicht so schlecht sind immer panik
gemacht aber so schlecht ist sie nicht
ich verstehe nicht was heute wirklich
der boden dafür war für diese
entscheidung für mich ist es nicht ich
verstehe die antwort dann ist demokraten
ist weil die mehrheit der abgeordneten
diese auffassung und das stichwort
glaube ich ist gesichts maßnahmen das
ist ja jetzt immer wieder heute auch
gefallen das ist ja auch in der sitzung
des fraktionsvorstandes der union am
freitag gefallen vorsichtsmaßnahmen also
man macht etwas aus vorsicht das ist ein
anderes staatsverständnis als du es hast
als wahrscheinlich wir alle in der runde
es hier haben das ist so ein bisschen
staatsverständnis vielleicht aus dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert das ist der
start der aufpassen muss dass dubai
bloss nicht richtig weist behütet werden
muss und das ist auch nicht verstanden
was ich tue ich aber es kommt kaum
steigt darauf an um was es geht bei
leben und tod finde ich schon ganz gut
dass an vielbefahrenen kreuzungen an
wünscht sie haben der andere lage da
waren ja auch gesagt wir haben jetzt
hier noch eine ganz andere als sie zum
beispiel im april 2020 gewesen oder im
märz 2020 und dann zu sagen wir machen
das jetzt hier verlängern etwas wissen
dass die lage sich verändert hat aber
machen das als vorsichtsmaßnahme dann
dann in der logik müsste der staat auch
das autofahren verbieten oder das
fahrrad mal das rauchen noch um
vorsichtsmaßnahmen geht das rauchen kann
müsst ihr auch verdienen müsste ganz
ganz viel verbieten wenn er sagt
vorsichtsmaßnahme vorsichtig ob da ist
dann doch irgend einem gewissen
zeitpunkt wieder auch die
eigenverantwortung dann entscheidend und
ich glaube es ist der entscheidende
punkt du ja auch machen wollte ist also
wann wann dreht sich das widerum es hat
sich vieles geändert und rhein zu sagen
eine vorsichtsmaßnahme deswegen setzen
wir noch so ein paar rechte außer kraft
ich glaube das darf ein demokratischer
rechtsstaat sich nicht leisten fühlst du
dich bevor musste den letzten monat also
in bevormundend ich bin geimpft ich bin
doppel geimpft also bevormundet ja
natürlich ich bin auch wie oli in der
unterhaltungsbranche das ist natürlich
alles alles alles andere als einfach
also für dich ist es ja noch schwieriger
du bist vor publikum du hast vor vielen
leuten du willst entertainer willst
ausmachen und so dass es da waren wir ja
im endeffekt habe ja noch auf holz
klopfen können wir durften fernsehen
immer weiter machen zwar auf einem
anderen level aber bevormundet also wie
gesagt wenn man noch mal so im geimpfte
und nicht geimpfte betrachtet also die
leute ich dass man es würden jetzt ganz
viele ja sagen ob das kann man nicht
miteinander vergleichen aber es wird
alles in sich rein gestoppt es wird
alles gegessen es wird fast food in sich
rein gestoppt es wird geraucht es wird
gesoffen bis der arzt kommt und da
hinterher sagt man was den stoff kann
ich nicht nehmen ich weiß nicht was ich
mir da
ist der klassiker ich weiß da würden
jetzt viele sagen ja das kann man jetzt
nicht miteinander vergleichen aber wir
haben jetzt so viele leute durchgeimpft
und wenn man sich mal dann anschaut was
ist denn wirklich danach jetzt
großartiges passiert wo bleiben denn die
unfassbaren horrorstorys von den
impfschäden die haben wir einfach noch
nicht gehabt so und deswegen verstehe
ich die angst vor dem impfen ehrlich
gesagt überhaupt nicht ich finde es gibt
in horror schaden aus der ganzen lage
nämlich dass der staat verstanden hat
dass die bürger vieles mit sich machen
lassen und gehört bei den themen die du
nennst also vielleicht kommt ihr als
nächstes
zucker verbot gefährlich ja also das ist
aber noch viel niedriger einkommen zu
meinem glück hatte überzeugt die
ausgangssperre hat ihr euch vorstellen
können dass wir mal irgendwie zu haus
sitzen müssen nicht raus polizeiautos
rumfahren und kommt dann vielleicht als
nächstes unsere klimaziele die müssen
wir bis 2023 25 30 erreicht da ist ja
selbstverständlich heißt es dann dass
man abends nicht mehr ausgeht weil da
atmet man aus fährt auto in der stadt
viele leute sagen oder zu einem gewissen
bruderduell mit lämmkom häufig sehen ja
sagen du darfst nur bis 3 und so macht
euch das nicht so ich habe da vielleicht
habe ich dann eine paranoia was aber ich
mache das sage das ist ein bisschen zu
viel ist das schöne werden zu der zeit
als es um diese ausgangssperre gegen was
total egal ist wenn man hätte ausgehen
können es gab ja nicht zu machen also es
hat ja keinen
aber sagen darf jetzt nicht wo die
schüler leidet er hat einen hund oder
will einkaufen oli pocher muss doch in
der runde und sich dann wundern
wo ich
einkaufen gehen kann ich bin doch ich
hoffe ich bin noch viel besser als alle
anderen nein oder auf das alkoholverbot
ab 22 das sind ja so weit gegangen dass
ich bei meinem kirst den wein einfach
immer einen mantel geteilt täter
bezeichnet
aber bezahlen was sollte am nächsten tag
nicht abgeschrieben das heißt ich wurde
vom staat dazu gezwungen weiß 2005 war
ich mit meinem kiosk verkäuferin das
jetzt zu machen problem ist ich das
schlimme ist ich kann das auch nicht so
ich kann das nur bedingt ernst nehmen
also ich merke ja selber man darf es
eigentlich nicht laut sagen aber viele
dieser regeln sind ja eh nicht
kontrollierbar und werden nicht
umgesetzt also ich auch ich war jetzt
wenn ich im ausland bin sondern was
anderes kontrolliert ja eh nicht
wirklich also ich merke halt immer wenn
man dann doch irgendwo fliegt was man
vorher sich alles anmelden muss damit
ich dann nur durchgewunken werde oder
halt mal jemand was nicht gerade recht
also das ist ja wirklich dann die die
endgültige aufgabe eines
funktionierenden staates ein staat der
regeln macht die im zweifel völlig
absurd sind ja weil dann aber sagt wir
aber richtig kontrollieren kann ich sie
gar nicht also ich wahrscheinlich muss
sich ein staaten machen denn wenn er das
doch nicht mal einheit ich bin jetzt in
einer ganz schwierigen position weil ich
halt auch immer jemanden bin nicht nur
im humoristischen bereich auch sonst ich
teste grenzen aus und ich checke
natürlich inwieweit ist es denn so und
und dann fahre ich auch mit dem auto
über den grenzern merke ich dass
kontrolliert eh keiner ja dann fange ich
auch irgendwann nicht mehr richtig test
oder irgendwas anderes zu machen weil es
einfach nicht kontrolliert werden kann
und ich weiß doch auch wenn ich irgendwo
im urlaub fliege ob dann in eine von eur
wings oder so da irgendwie mal so 0,3
sekunden drauf guckt und ich denke das
ist ein pc ersatz für 70 euro
nämlich den von vorgestern
man kann doch so eine pdf datei kann man
ja auch verändern und guckt keiner drauf
jetzt irgendwie ist das hast du doch
nicht machen möchtest du auch nicht
stören aber es ist leider so aber die
leute lassen sich von dieser
grundsätzlichen angst in
anführungsstrichen natürlich so ein
bisschen einschüchtern und das finde ich
halt mittelmäßig aber ich finde es gibt
schon jetzt ein aufbegehren also was
anderes ob impfpflicht oder ob man sich
auch gegen solche regeln mittlerweile
auch auflehnen sollte was man halt
machen wir sehen ja so viele absurde
regel nicht aber es war ein guter punkt
der gemacht wird wir sehen so viele
absurde regeln die es gibt also ich habe
das selbst festgestellt in der deutschen
bahn wenn man da ja sobald der schall
wird ja von mir aus meinem vom streik
sind aber auch beim streik natürlich
aber man fährt von zu hause los
natürlich ohne maske ist ja ein haushalt
mit frau und kindern so und dann sitzt
man aber in einem abteil auch nur als
familie und muss maske tragen zu hause
nicht im auto nicht aber sobald man in
der bahn ist und ganz allein da sitzt
muss man wird sehen was getragen das
versteht keiner klar das thema streik
darüber brauchen wir gar nicht zu reden
aber eigentlich der gdl-chef jetzigen
geflogen konntet ihr ist raus
recherchiere ich glaube ich dass ich
sagen muss
geheim bleiben das hätte ich gerne
gewusst dass sondern ich will keine
angaben nach der sendung danke wir
machen jetzt ganz kurz
[Musik]